everybody
people have delivered their verdict
freedom is here to stay
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
I was screaming because I was bleeding I
was throwing up and Grandson just looked
at me he was like looking at me and
talking to others smiling and laughing
[Music]
with me as Governor we
raise taxes and we will never have an
income tax
[Music]
what they've done by advocating things
like the sexualization of children very
close relationship with the Chinese
Communist party you know that's all very
problematic
[Music]
[Applause]
we've accomplished more than anybody
thought possible four years ago but
we've got so much more to do and I have
only begun to fight God bless you all
thank you very much thank you for a
historic Landslide victory
[Music]